haha the Joe Rogan experience that's
another perspective thing I've noticed
too yes that it's a mentality that it's
way more pervasive than it needs to be
right the the way that people look at
success
I was raised but my mom and I should be
a [ __ ] failure to be honest with you
I am like the epitome of having a
background where I should be
nothing my mom was like look if Tim why
not you and not meaning any specific
race or any specific type of people but
just anything if you want something and
you see someone that has something that
you want work and figure out a way so
that you can get it that should be a
motivation not something I look down on
and say well why do they get to have
that that's not fair I should have that
I think there's too much of that thought
process and mentality in this country
it's a mind is it yeah and I think it's
scary it's scary because then what it
does is abilify success and so now
instead of set success being something
that people aspire to it's now become
something that people attack yes and I
think that's incredibly dangerous
incredibly dangerous yeah I agree it's
it's a very weak minded perspective -
there's one kind of mean there's
different kinds of success - right
this is success of someone who built a
business versus success of someone who's
doing some shady [ __ ] with mister with
loans and you know and in [ __ ] over
people with you know subprime mortgages
and that there's there's different
things that make you successful you know
there's the wolf of Wall Street money
that you get from ripping people off but
I think that goes without being said
though yes that that's pretty blatant
but it's also like the gun problem and
people are messy yeah you know everybody
was like you know one would have a
problem with guns it's it's a messy
problem that comes with it as human
beings cuz we're just weird people are
weird
no you're right and I but here's a funny
thing though like I have this kind of
utopic vision of this this like mass
education on firearms and the reason I
have it and I know it's a little naive
to a degree but I do believe like the
gun changed the way I looked at the
world and I think the gun like a lot of
like you know
to change the way you look at the world
it taught me to worry even though my mom
really kind of beat it into my head the
gun almost served as like a physical
symbol of self-reliance not that I don't
need anyone but to trust in my own
ability to find a way to deal with any
problems that I have
sometimes that ability means go to
somebody who's better at it than you
that can help you do something to learn
exactly or it means find a strength
within yourself to overcome a issue that
you're dealing with the gun showed me
and not only told me that they taught me
responsibility because now we are
talking however I want to Disney fie it
as far as the the sporting enthusiast
aspect of it it's still something it's
life and death that is a tool of life
and death that can be used to take a
life and can be used to save one so
because of that that Deborah is a big
responsibility especially when I'm
carrying that very thing on me
everywhere I go so it had me really
appreciate life more I started to value
life a lot more most people think you
get a gun and all something you just
want to take life no like the I tell you
this all time the day I have to use the
gun to defend myself I'm gonna need
therapy flat-out I'm gonna need therapy
because it's made me value life there
not that I didn't buy you like before
but it's something that brings it to the
forefront of your consciousness when you
have a gun and you understand what that
gun can be used to do hmm and so that
happens to way more people than people
realize most people think that people
get a gun and they just become reckless
murderers we want to kill everybody when
in reality there are a number of stories
of people out there who I know a guy who
the firearm helped them get out of his
depression I know I know
I sounds crazy it sounds crazy but he'll
he'll he'll tell you the speech about it
right and he's and he's very he should
be I mean he grew up in the streets of
st. Louis and he didn't he didn't have a
good life he was young and he was
depressed but when he got into firearms
that allowed him to deal with his
depression because it found something he
was passionate about isn't that that is
crazy but that's something that does
actually work when you find something
you really love and pursue it and you
get some like
that's one of the problems I have with
the term depression like boy that's a
blanket that you throw over so many
different factors yeah like what it's
almost like the term drugs like if you
say you want drugs yeah I drank a cup of
coffee it's weird yeah
the depression is in many ways like that
in that there are people and I know
these people that have a real problem
with their brain and the way the brain
produces chemicals same way some people
have problems with their liver
some people have they're born with
ineffective lungs these are all just
parts of us being a person yeah and some
people have like legitimate issues that
I think they need medication for and
then there's other people that they just
don't feel good and they call it
depression because their life sucks and
their job sucks and no one wants to have
sex with them and they don't have any
money so they're depressed yeah and they
say I'm suffering from depression and so
what do you do with that well some of
those people get on medication and I
don't know if that's really the answer
because there's a lot of those people
that I know that have discovered
jiu-jitsu or discovered other things
that they yo --ga either physical things
often because they release endorphins
and cuz they're actually healthy for you
but also you get passionate about
something and you see this improvement
and what you were talking about that
with guns I was trying to describe to
someone why I like shooting guns I said
one of the reasons why I like is I'm not
very good at it yeah you know I like
learning things I like learning all
kinds of the
[Applause]